[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today pulsars and neutron stars
from earth the night sky shines with a
multitude of bright speckles
for the most part these are stars huge
balls of plasma infusion
that radiate intense light due to their
high temperature
although they twinkle slightly due to
disturbances in the atmosphere
the brightness of stars is fairly stable
but in the 1960s observing the sky
in other wavelengths astronomers
discovered bright spots that
flicker over time these points
seem to emit extremely regular
oscillations
their luminosity pulses in a metronomic
way
we call them pulsars
to understand where these pulsars come
from we will have to immerse ourselves
in the life of a star
we are interested in a star 10 times
more massive
than our sun during its lifetime
the star burns its fuel in a process of
nuclear fusion
the core of the star releases energy
outwards
which allows it to counterbalance the
pressure of gravity
and thus remain stable
at the end of its existence after a
hundred million years
our star is exhausted it is run out of
fuel
and the nuclear fusion in its core stops
the star is no longer in equilibrium
nothing opposes the pull of gravity
and the core begins to collapse under
its weight
as it shrinks the star's core compresses
its temperature rises to several billion
degrees and it begins to spin
faster and faster generating an
increasingly powerful magnetic field
after a while the core becomes so dense
that the particles that make up matter
are forced to merge electrons enter the
nuclei of atoms
and combine with protons they form
neutrons
and in the process reject a tremendous
amount of neutrinos
suddenly the core becomes so small that
neutrons collide with each other
at this point the core can no longer
shrink
the contraction stops abruptly and the
outer layers of the star are violently
blown away by the shock wave
and the wind of neutrinos the star
explodes
it's a supernova
the supernova explosion leaves behind a
gigantic
remnant a cloud of interstellar gas and
dust
which may one day give birth to new
stars
but after its death the core of the star
has not vanished
it is still there but it is now a tiny
ball of mata
formed of neutrons stacked together this
is a type of stellar corpse
called a neutron star
when they form neutron stars can occur
in different configurations
many stars for example orbit in pairs in
binary systems
around another star after the death of
one of them
the neutron star it leaves behind can
sometimes continue to revolve around its
partner
similarly if the star was initially
surrounded by planets
these will sometimes continue orbiting
the corpse
[Music]
a neutron star is an incredibly dense
object
which contains the mass of several suns
in a few dozens of kilometers
this is the equivalent of the mass of
pluto squeezed to fit inside a house
if it were compressed even slightly more
gravity would take over
and it would turn into a black hole
the neutron star is also extremely hot
in some cases surface temperature can
exceed several million degrees
[Music]
due to its small size it spins extremely
quickly
while it shrinked the core that formed
the neutron star
accelerated until reaching near light
speed velocities
a neutron star can rotate almost a
thousand times on itself
in just a second a car with wheels
turning this fast
would move at 7 000 kilometers per hour
on the surface of a neutron star gravity
is unbearable
and gives rise to strange phenomena from
relativity
first of all time is greatly dilated
if astronauts landed on the neutron star
they would only age
10 months for each year that passes on
earth
unfortunately for them the tidal forces
are also insufferable
the difference of pull between their
head and their feet is here a hundred
million times
stronger than earth's gravity they would
instantly get
spaghettified finally
the neutron star deflects light rays
around it bending the geometry of
space-time
like a black hole it creates a
gravitational lensing effect
distorting the image of surrounding
objects and even allowing us to observe
its rear
[Music]
the internal structure of a neutron star
is still poorly understood
small and very distant it is impossible
to observe their composition from earth
we have to rely on mathematical models
and quantum physics
to describe how mata compresses
[Music]
at the surface a neutron star is most
likely surrounded by a thin atmosphere
no thicker than a human hair under which
lies a
perfectly smooth surface as the strong
gravity
flattens any roughness that would
protrude
under its surface the neutron star has a
crust
mainly solid made up of atomic nuclei
and free electrons
as we dive deeper the pressure increases
and the nuclei begin to combine with the
electrons
to form neutrons the high pressure helps
stabilize these heavy nuclei
which would normally decay very quickly
deeper and deeper the nuclei combine
with each other
and merge to form even larger clusters
the more we dive into the crust the more
the competition between gravity
electromagnetism and the strong
interaction
forces these clumps of matter to merge
together
further down the nuclei form long
structures in the shape of tubes
[Music]
deeper still these tubes are forced
against
each other and merge to form a pile of
layers
stacked on top of one another
finally these layers fuse together and
the spaces gradually close
leaving only a few bubbles in a liquid
of neutrons
these different structures that make up
geometric networks
inside the crust would constitute one of
the strongest materials in the universe
a sort of large-scale atomic nucleus
which researchers called
nuclear pasta the geometry is indeed
reminiscent of gnocchi
spaghetti or lasagna names that
scientists use
to classify them intuitively
if we decide to dive even deeper we
venture beyond the limits of the crust
and enter the core of the neutron star
where the pressure is greatest
the core of a neutron star is an
extremely difficult region to describe
it reaches the current limits of our
models
the pressure is so intense that the
principles of quantum physics come into
play
in particular the particles are so close
together that they repel each other by
the simple
fact that they mustn't overlap this is
called
the exclusion principle the form of mata
whose structure is governed by the
exclusion principle
is called degenerate matter
degenerate matter is still mysterious
and there are several different
hypotheses
about its structure it could simply be
neutrons stuck together
but neutrons are not elementary
particles they are themselves made up of
quarks
and one could imagine that under such
pressures the quarks would separate to
form a superfluid
or even a plasma of quarks and gluons
whose properties
would be exotic
the insides of a neutron star still
remain an enigma which researchers are
actively trying to solve
during its formation the neutron star
acquired an extremely powerful magnetic
field
on earth scientists are able to generate
magnetic fields of several dozens of
tesla
enough to levitate objects and even
living beings
but a neutron star generates a magnetic
field that is several million
times stronger such a magnetic field is
so intense
that it can even alter the vacuum itself
it provides space with weird quantum
refraction properties
light moving by may be deflected split
or recombined
just like a magnet the magnetic field of
a neutron star
exits through a north pole wraps around
the star
and enters it through a south pole the
neutron star therefore has a magnetic
axis which in most cases is not aligned
with its axis of rotation
when it spins the magnetic field of the
neutron star follows this rotation
creating intense fluctuations which
propagate
at the speed of light
reasonably close the magnetic field of
the neutron star
traps the surrounding matter and forces
it to stay near the star
conversely at a great distance the
magnetic field
varies so quickly that it opens and
accelerates
charged particles outwards in this way
the neutron star produces two beams of
extremely
powerful electromagnetic waves that
escape
along its magnetic axis
like a cosmic lighthouse these radiation
beams sweep space periodically
and emit a signal whose oscillations
pulse metronomically
when earth is in the way we observe a
tiny bright spot
which flickers in the sky it is a pulsar
since the 1960s pulsar observations have
been listed and classified
according to their frequency of
oscillation
the faster the nutrient star spins on
itself the faster the pulses we observe
on earth
we can categorize different populations
of pulsars
some spin very quickly at almost a
thousand rotations per second
most of these very fast pulsars occur in
binary systems
orbiting a star they are able to
accelerate to these extreme speeds
by capturing some matter from their
companion
conversely other pulsars spin more
slowly
at the rate of a few revolutions per
minute
the rotation of a neutron star is
extremely stable
its precision is comparable to that of
our best atomic clocks
but during the thousands of years of its
existence it slowly loses energy
magnetic energy and gravitational energy
in the curvature of space-time gradually
pulsars lose speed and end up performing
only a few rotations per minute
during this slowing down process the
surface of the star adjusts to the
centrifugal force which becomes weaker
and takes a more spherical shape
suddenly the surface falls down a few
micrometers
in less than a millionth of a second
these phenomena have the effect of
slightly accelerating
the rotation of the star
usually the populations of pulsars are
classified in a diagram
which shows their rotation speed against
the rate at which they slow down
we find binary pulsars which rotate very
quickly and are very stable
and slower pulsars which slow down over
time
from earth we observe all types of
radiation
most pulsars emit radio waves but others
can emit more energetic
x-rays because of their rotation and
very strong magnetic field
or even gamma rays
some of these pulsars have magnetic
fields so strong
we call them magnetars
[Music]
they emit powerful x-rays and gamma rays
in an irregular way
which makes them very difficult to
[Music]
describe
today we know of nearly 3 000 pulsars in
our galaxy
unfortunately the vast majority of
neutron stars
remain unobservable from earth most of
them have very thin beams that don't
sweep our sky
and our current telescopes can only
detect the most active pulsars
these objects are still mysterious they
raise astronomical
physical and mathematical questions that
have yet
to be answered but pulsars are of
unprecedented interest in the world of
astronomy
they can allow us to probe into the
theory of general relativity to its most
extreme limits allow us to understand
the behavior of mata
under such intense pressures they
provide us with cosmic clocks
of extraordinary stability and their
study could contain
clues as to the behavior of
gravitational waves
indirectly pulsars could tell us about
the nature of dark matter
and the existence of primordial black
holes
pulsars are also very good reference
points for satellites to orient
themselves
and finally it is around a pulsar that
we observed
the very first exoplanets
[Music]
you